[música]
pasillo voló
por ti me sentaré
[música]
justo en frente de la dama y en frente de mi esta el juego
prisioneros
[música]
tanto después del bombardeo del puente con granizo en
golpe de casa
[música]
sí
la fábrica fue asesinada, por supuesto, en absoluto
tarly 2 vidrio volado lo karl 4
llegada al final del letrero Kherson la tenemos
ver si puedo
consentido
Cuándo
me gusta
si Kherson
pero
[música]
[reír]
espacio sdo en ucrania
somos los blancos de la casa blanca
tejiendo un maldito arco de señas ahora
el expediente se lleva
[música]
[aplausos]
hoy todos esperábamos a un hombre guapo
a la [ __ ] todo bien hecho nadie
nada nos llevó y todos los camiones están llenos
volver a la [ __ ] de donde vinieron
[aplausos]
Ucrania
[música]
ratones
[aplausos]